youtubers is Charlie this is going to be
my Sherlock finale videos they did a
great job of weaving everything together
going back to season one just careful
for spoilers if you haven't seen it yet
because this is the last episode of
Sherlock probably for a long time I have
some notes at the end of this about
what's coming next in what the cast and
crew have said so there is a new round
of the Sherlock giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video be sure to click
that Bell to enable alerts so that you
don't miss anything so there's just like
so many things to talk about do this in
the top 10 format although there should
be 15 so number 10 that really funny
Mycroft horror introduction it's almost
like he's in a dream sequence but you
get the reveal that Sherlock just staged
it so that he becomes so afraid and
reveal the truth Sherlock has a sister
the way they pull that off was perfect
like Mycroft murder House is he's
watching this old Pope's detective
thriller it's funny to watch Mycroft
express emotion because supposedly he's
not supposed to have any like he makes
the joke later in the episode where
Sherlock's almost forced to kill him
where he says you know I might have a
little heart why don't you aim for that
so the cats out of the bag Mycroft comes
clean in number 9 is forced to go to
Baker Street for help just like any
other clients so he has to sit in the
chair jump through all the hoops so
there's all the comedy of that but then
he explains your OSes backstory she's
one year older than Sherlock but six
years younger than Mycroft so you get a
little more context for her character
the funny thing about this is that cher
inferred in the books the third mythical
brother of the home was supposed to be
the smartest of all like towering above
Mycroft himself so they did that in this
episode but because his euros it's a
sister it's a different name so she has
this Titanic genius that Dwarfs the
other Holmes brothers but she's being
kept secret this whole time because
she's such a danger to herself to
everyone else so number 8 the share
inferred reveal like I said it's the
name of the mythical third Holmes
brother that wasn't written by Conan
Doyle it's not really part of the Canon
it was just a theoretical thing it was
added later to sort of sew up the logic
he used it as the name for this Alcatraz
prison that she's stuck in I should
actually say that the title of the
episode is also an easter egg for the
Conan Doyle story the adventure of the
final problem which was meant to be the
last Sherlock Holmes story he was going
to kill the character off but then fans
revolted he brought him back later but
originally the final problem was sort of
like the Reichenbach fall where he went
out taking down Moriarty they used that
during the Christmas special where he's
in his mind palace at the Reichenbach
Fall so originally that was meant to be
the theoretical death of the character
in the books but in the episode they
used it as a sort of Easter Egg for
Sherlock's obsession with deep water
that goes back to red beard so family
backstory number seven Musgrave we learn
about their ancestral home if you saw
the James Bond movie Skyfall it's kind
of like that it's just like this really
old home that had been in their family
for a long time there are all these fake
graves out front that Sherlock was
obsessed with that his sister used as
the cipher for the east wind riddle that
she kept repeating so she turned it into
a song but the code for solving it was
taken from the graves that Sherlock
liked to play around as a child when he
was playing pirates with his friends
number six the prison takeover so
there's this big reveal that she's in
this Sharon furred prison the most
impregnable fortress where you lock up
the worst of the worst
they set it up pretty hardcore so no
surprise that the reveal then is that
Hannibal Lecter is actually running the
prison so it was a great twist where
it's like oh we all spend time with her
she all turned us so we're following her
orders but the bigger one number five is
the Moriarty reveal where you learned
that Mycroft had been using her genius
to help stop future potential crimes but
as a result was forced to give her
things in exchange one of them was the
violin the other was five uninterrupted
minutes with Moriarty five years ago so
there was this great introduction
sequence where they don't reveal to you
that it's in the past
Moriarty gets off the helicopter to
Queen just like a total boss just like
it's so great
bag doing a little dance for the fans
everyone's going crazy but then you
learned that it's five years ago and
he's actually been playing euro tsa's
great game the great game that Moriarty
teased is actually her great game that
she set in motion to get Sherlock to
help save her
so on route to this there's a whole
bunch of Easter eggs the case that she
forces him to solve the three Garrideb
brothers is actually named after the
adventure of the three garrotted which i
actually think they used as a series 3
episode two but she puts into this
emotional wringer just sort of like Lab
Rats just seeing how they'll react how
their morality will adapt to the
situation like will you do something
that you never thought that you would do
nice moment from Mycroft that proves
that he's not a total psychopath he
actually does have emotion tries to get
Sherlock to kill him so that he won't
have to kill Watson but then she knocks
them out takes them back to their family
home and Sherlock learns the truth
number four that there was no red beard
the dog it was actually his friend in
that part of the reason why Sherlock
doesn't remember his sister is because
he rewrote his memories because the
trauma of losing his friend was so bad
that was the day that he started to push
emotions out and be the Sherlock that
you met in the first season but number
three as he saved his sister helps bring
her down so to speak from her mind
palace where she was trapped up in the
air he also learned that he's stronger
because of his emotions and he should
welcome that so he's never going to be
as smart as Mycroft or euros but he will
always beat them because he's a stronger
person so not smarter but stronger
because he's learned to not push his
emotions away so you know his friendship
with Watson helped teach him that so you
kind of see that play out over the
course of the episode the Molly Hooper I
love you moment also kind of plays into
that too but number two you see Sherlock
visiting his sister later just showing
you a more hopeful ending that she's no
longer alone there's this big reveal
that she's beyond words she can't
communicate she's not talking to anyone
but Sherlock can speak to her through
music so even if she isn't literally
talking she's still communicating with
them now you see the family
come visit Mycroft telling his parents
look she's still alive so they
eventually go visit her so they imply
that she gets well enough so they can
actually have a relationship with her
even if it's still kind of weird and
she's locked up for the rest of her life
but number one is the message from Mary
just making you wonder you know miss you
you're like oh my god is this going to
be some sort of Moriarty reveal but it's
just another final message from Mary
giving them a big call-to-action
explaining why what they do as they
solve crimes have these adventures is so
necessary for the people that need them
so she's just telling them that they
need to carry on they do this big
montage where there's like a couple more
Easter eggs the Viking on the floor
there is actually the musician paul
weller who's part like this big band
called the jam your big musician big
rock star that also happens to be a
friend of Martin Freeman so that's sort
of like a celebrity cameo the Rathbone
place is an Easter Egg for Basil
Rathbone who played the character in the
1939 film series but you see Rosie you
see Molly Hooper so she's not really
dead so it's just sort of like a goodbye
in a way for them to show you that
they're still having adventures
regardless of whether or not they're
going to be more Sherlock episodes so in
a lot of you are asking the cast and
crew as soon as they want to do more
Sherlock episodes but if they do it's
going to be like another two years at
least before there are more so if they
decide to do more it is going to be a
long time but we'll probably hear you
know whether or not it's actually going
to happen relatively quickly the other
really funny thing this is just like a
small moment from the first time he met
euros it's like a lingering question I
think you know just to kind of poke the
fans a little like you can wonder about
this but we're not going to answer it
for sure is when euros says to Sherlock
is he's playing the violin you've had
sex
I can tell I've had sex and for a minute
you just kind of stop and say wait a
minute
who did Sherlock have sex with it wasn't
with Molly Hooper for sure and I think
that they answered that he did not have
sex with Jeanine so you wonder is like
is Irene Adler I thought that she was
mostly into women maybe she's bisexual
so just a really funny tease for the
fans do you guys let me know like what
was your favorite moment from the
episode in which episode was your
favorite so far I definitely think this
is one of my favorites but I feel like
see
three was a little bit stronger so I'm
gonna have to go back and re-watch these
again but it was a great run this year
episode 2 and episode 3 definitely
better than the first episode but if he
did spot any other Easter eggs that it
didn't mention there's probably a whole
bunch just let me know in the comments
and I'll say congratulations to this
week's Sherlock giveaway winner on kala
bond you win a $20 Amazon gift card just
be sure to private message me on the
back end of my channel so I can get your
contact details what's going to happen
is is because Game of Thrones is still a
ways away and there's not a lot of
Doctor Who happening if you're big
Sherlock fan and you're looking for like
another series that's kind of in the
same vein
I'd recommend taboo which is Tom Hardy's
new miniseries that's on FX networks in
the United States
I think it's on sky in the UK but the
other new series that I'm going to be
doing videos for is called Legion which
is like an x-men TV show about the most
powerful mutant but it's kind of like
x-men Breaking Bad it's going to be
carried on Fox's international channels
so whichever channel you watch The
Walking Dead on that's the channel that
Legion is going to be on is a Thursday
show I'll be doing a trailer video in
the next couple of days that will
explain what's going on with that what
you guys wait for that to post you can
click here for all my Sherlock videos
and you can click here for my latest
Game of Thrones video thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you